[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Franco
and L Fus hi Franco how are you hey Dave
hey George uh very excited to be talking
to you today sure what's
up uh so my question for for today it's
um should I buy out my ex-wife out of
the house or should I keep waiting for
the house to sell considering the slow
months
ahead um so to give a little background
on that um I recently went through a
divorce that finished about a month ago
it lasted for about eight months um and
since uh since the beginning of the
relationship and even beginning of the
divorce I've been paying for the
mortgage for all the bills related to
the house and for all the debts that
she's carrying uh right now plus the
three dogs that we used to have together
um your paying three dogs that you used
to
have I'm so
confused why would you be paying for
dogs that you don't have for an
ex-wife because uh since the beginning
of the relationship she basically
decided not to work even if I encourage
her I even pay
her have you got the
dogs no I don't then they're no longer
your
responsibility okay if you want to take
care of the dog go get them but
otherwise quit paying for the freaking
dogs for your
exwife come on man now and so she's in
the house she's in the house yes and
you're paying all the and what did the
divorce decree say about the house it
had to be sold uh yes it's in the
process of being sold uh it's been
through months in the market with a lot
of showings but it hasn't been sold yet
okay and and you're paying the payment
yes I'm making the payment and I'm
paying uh the bills related to the house
as well okay and she's living in the
house yes what a wonderful
deal I bet I bet it's hard to show that
house and when you do it's
messy uh I I'm actually not allowed to
enter the house she prefers uh for me
not to so what makes you think you can
buy her
out um so I've been uh thinking that uh
I could buy the portion that it will be
the same uh for her if the house gets
sold is she going to move with the dogs
then yes you sure if I do so I mean I I
would hope so so far you've not done
very good
deals yeah she's got to move you
understand that yeah I do and the dogs
at what point do you stop paying all of
her bills when the house sells yeah are
we sure about that uh yes it's part of
the divorce decree yeah but is Franco
gonna
quit oh yeah yeah yeah I'm GNA quit I've
been how much do it take to buy her
out uh about
50,000 okay but it's not worth that
because after after expenses you're not
going to net 50 on half you're not
netting a full 100 when it sells are
you uh so the price of the house is
about uh on the market 630 right now and
because we still owe uh a big amount on
on the
house uh we uh about
450 okay is not yeah that's about right
then okay if you can come up with 50,000
and you want to buy her out and sell the
house yourself later but she's got to
leave and I don't think she's going to